these navy commandos
are setting out on a hunt for pirates at
sea
it's a dangerous assignment that
security forces of this small west
african nation
have been carrying out for years they
face pirates and
armed criminal gangs that seize cargoes
and kidnap crew members for ransom
at sea the team escorts vessels in and
out of the maritime hub of cotton
benin's economic nerve center they're in
constant touch with their operation base
where larger vessels stand by to deploy
in case of bigger threats
these operations led to a significant
decrease in illegal activities
it's a dangerous operation but we're
professional officers who are well
trained to do just that
for three consecutive years the gulf of
guinea has been the world's most
dangerous shipping road
more than half of attacks at sea happen
here a maritime territory that covers
nearly two and a half
million square kilometers the
international maritime bureau documented
195 pirate attacks
in the gulf of guinea last year 32 more
than the previous year
benin's navy says only one of those
attacks happened in its territorial
waters
and it wants to keep it that way so it's
asking merchant ships
coming into its waters to also hire
private security
to enhance safety
every year the sophistication of the
attacks has grown and countries of the
region
desperate not to lose control of the
maritime and economic lifelines
are looking
previously the pirates target tankers
but now any ship is a target and they
have vessels that travel
far offshore although the criminals
attack close to shore as well
at the naval headquarters new speed
boats are prepared for deployment
the navy chief says bigger vessels are
on their way to reinforce operations
and for the right reasons beneath
protein cotton handles 90 percent of its
foreign trade
and generates more than 60 percent of
its gdp
it processes 12 million tons of freight
annually
if their any attacks on ships in our
areas
we feel it it affects our revenues from
duties
all attacks or even an attempted
negatively impact the country's economy
we are not only investing to tackle
attacks but also preventing them
more important to us is preventing
attacks because intervention costs more
in terms of money
and human lives benin has an evil force
of only a few hundred personnel
but is able to effectively reduce
attacks in its territorial waters
and officials here say if more countries
in the gulf of guinea collaborated more
closely
shipping routes would become much safer
ahamad idris al jazeera kotono